[Music]
deepak welcome to the show
thanks you're very well dressed thank
you yes
it's interesting you are uh a uh an
expert on the mind and on people's
spiritual health what are you getting
from me right now and and please be
honest seriously a desperate need for
approval
yes that sounds just about
right also a narcissistic personality
you know i was fine with just stopping
after the first one
and that doesn't take an expert
[Laughter]
whose side are you on tonight
the fans
[Applause]
all right
do you see any is there is there a ray
of hope for me at all i mean i'm
desperately narcissistic i have a sick
need for approval come on give me some
good yeah there is hope because actually
you're a very spiritual person as well
you make people laugh and make them
happy
and that is a spiritual faith you're
also
in a sense you know you're full of
paradox contradiction
ambiguity insecurity
and
that
those are spiritual traits actually
because
you're an authentic fake
hold it this is the good news
you know
i'm an authentic face i was just in las
vegas for the cs um
yes yes that's where all the techies are
yeah and i was there also talking about
the dreamweaver which we'll talk about
later
but you know las vegas is the most
spiritual city in the world but you
think las vegas is the most spiritual
city in the world why because it doesn't
pretend to be what it's not
oh that's actually
yes
yes
it's about time someone gave it up for
las vegas
i want to make sure we get to the book
because we have a lot to cover uh you
are talking about there are two kinds of
brain in the super brain you talk about
two kinds of brains super brain and
baseline brain
tell us what you mean by that the
baseline brain is automatic it's taking
care of your heart rate your autonomic
nervous system hormone levels it runs
you but the super brain is when you run
it when you have access to insight
intuition
choice free will creativity imagination
your brain is a three-pound universe
that projects your universe so once you
know how to use your brain
you change your reality